a major obstacle to self-knowledge and
in turned to a flourishing life is the
tendency of one part of our minds to lie
to the other we lie for what might
initially seem like a very
understandable reason because we want to
avoid pain but in so doing we hugely
damaged our chances of happiness there
are four things we particularly like to
lie to ourselves about we lie about all
the problematic aspects it would take so
much effort to alter our jobs our
relationships our friendships are held
four habits and ideas we lie because we
need to think well of ourselves and are
devoted to imagining that we are
essentially normal
without peculiar loves hates and deviant
thoughts we lie because we don't want to
feel so inadequate and yet because we
lack so many good things we lie because
we're furious with certain people we're
supposed to love and we lie because what
we furious about feels so minor and
pathetically petty for a grown-up to
care about given how risky the truth
about us can feel we've had to learn to
be Masters of Deception our techniques
are wide-ranging devilish and often
hugely imaginative here are some of the
leading maneuvers we employ to pull the
wool over our own eyes
we identify something that can
powerfully keep our thoughts away from
troubling inner confrontations online
pornography as a favorite the news
another alcohol of thirst work a fourth
we don't so much like these elements in
and of themselves we like them for their
ability to keep us away from what we
fear
a sadness we haven't been able to admit
to is often covered up with exaggerated
doses of mamak cheeriness we aren't
happy so much as incapable of allowing
ourselves to feel even the slightest
sadness in case we were to be
overwhelmed by our buried grief we
develop a brittle insistent tendency to
say that all is very well this is lovely
isn't it
we might press leaving no room for any
ideas to the contrary
denied anger with a particular personal
situation often seeps out into a
generalized irritability so successful
is the lie we don't really know what's
up we just keep losing our tempers
someone's moved the TV remote
there aren't any eggs in the fridge the
electricity bill is slightly higher than
we expected anything can set us off our
brains are so filled with how
frustrating or annoying things are we've
cleverly left in no space at all for
focusing on the true and very sad issue
we tell ourselves that we simply don't
care about something
love or politics career success or
intellectual life that beautiful student
or the house we can't afford and we are
very emphatic about our lack of interest
and complete disdain we go to great
lengths to make it very clear to others
and ourselves how absolutely unconcerned
we are
we grow censorious and deeply
disapproving of certain kinds of
behavior and people what we don't admit
is that we're so full of condemnation
only because we need to ward off
awareness that a part of us in fact
really likes the condemned element we
attack certain sexual tastes as utterly
deviant and beyond the pale
precisely because we half know that we
share them somewhere inside ourselves so
we're delighted when particular people
are arrested or shamed in the press
what they did was utterly awful we
insist our outrage shielding us from any
risk of spotting the connection between
them and us
when there's unwelcome news we may
resort to a highly successful
diversionary tactic taking offense a
colleague tries to give us a bit of
feedback instantly we accuse them of
rudeness arrogance and a sense of
entitlement a partner point something
out we get furious at they're piling
pressures on us at a difficult point
feeling offended takes up all our
attention it muddies the waters way
along how to pay attention to
information that is at heart
correct but challenging
we're sad about particular things but
confronting them would be so arduous we
generalize and universalize the sadness
we don't say that X or Y is made us sad
we say that everything is rather
terrible and everyone is rather awful we
spread the pain in order that it's
particular specific causes can no longer
be the focus of attention our sadness
gets to put it metaphorically lost in
the crowd
why is lying to ourselves a problem we
need to tell ourselves the truth when we
can for the simple reason that we often
pay a very high price for the short-term
calm of our lies we miss key
opportunities for growth and learning
we're not very nice to be around we
develop harmful systems and not least
the truth will out when we don't let it
emerge it has a tendency to reveal
itself through involuntary often
physical symptoms we become insomniac or
impotent an eyelid starts twitching we
acquire a stutter
we scream in our sleep we lose energy we
fall into depression we owe it to
ourselves to dare to start to confront
our real nature
you